I like to say that the real future of AI
is not artificial intelligence but
augmented introspection all of these
different theories of mind and theories
of self create opportunities for
redefining what we want
augmented introspection to be look at
Eric Byrnes transactional analysis
parent-child adults different ways of
thinking about the self Freud ego
Ede super-ego let's use the enormous
research that has gone on in psychology
about the nature of the self the nature
of the self as in the individual and the
nature of the self as the self relates
to other people and let's use technology
to create versions of the self that
allow for more efficacious more
effective more creative more innovative
more productive interactions I think
it's important to draw a distinction
between a cognitive tool and an
enhancement and a multiple self or a
version of oneself that amplifies
exaggerates improves enhances augments
some attribute that really matters to
you so here's a simple way of thinking
about this we have Google Maps it tells
you a way to go okay you're in a hurry
you're in such a hurry that you're
prepared to dare I say cut corners and
go through a stop sign or two that's
your bold impatient self
well should Google Maps make a
recommendation that supports your bold
impatient self or you're doing research
on Amazon you're you're looking for
books to read on a certain subject you
don't want the mainstream books that you
that the typical average normal you
ordered what about the you that
looks to challenge your fundamental
assumptions to stretch your thinking
what if you had a recommendation engine
that recommended stuff for you to read
that pushed your thinking that
challenged you that that kicked your
assumptions in the groin that's a
different kind of a tool now what do
these things have in common the self is
about agency it's about choice you
however you want to define it choose
what I'm saying AI machine learning and
recommenders and and smart recommenders
bespoke custom recommenders make
difference as that you can pick
different frontiers different boundaries
of yourself what aspect of yourself do
you most want to enhance in advance what
aspect of yourself do you want to
mitigate or suppress I think this cuts
both ways I think we're going to see
versions of the self that allow for
greater compassion less impatience so I
think it's important to think of the
self in a symmetrical way what are the
aspects we want to improve and augment
what are the aspects that we wish to
mitigate or ameliorate what's the common
denominator give people the choice this
is why I like recommendation engines so
much it's not they're not called you
have to do this engines they're not you
have to buy or watch this engines their
recommendation engines and you choose
what I'm proposing is we we're choosing
from the span and portfolio of multiple
versions of who we really are or who we
might become if that's what we want what
I have found so fascinating in this is
there are there's so much exciting and
compelling and groundbreaking work in
psychology sociology behavioral
economics about what is the self who is
the self
there's Nobel prize-winning work from
that Daniel Kahneman Thinking Fast and
Slow about you know the immediate self
and the more thoughtful slow process
self there's marvin minsky the late
marvin minsky one of the pioneers and
artificial intelligence who talked about
a society of mind and the modular brain
there's robert Kurzban there's jonathan
hate their social psychologists and
anthropologists who are looking at who
is the self what's the difference
between one's self and one's identity
and you know what the common denominator
to all of this is you are not you there
is no such thing according to empirical
scientific research there's no such
thing as the self
in fact the metaphor that many people
use is that your mind is like a
committee and that depending upon time
of day and your mood and how your brain
we talking about brain and mind is
working you might making one kind of
decision or choice versus another
oneself or aspect of the self may
dominate over another my insight is
let's use these different dimensions of
self as a design opportunity let's look
at the Society of mind and say what kind
of digital tools should support this
kind of society what Daniel Kahneman
Thinking Fast and Slow what kind of
nudges do we want to support the faster
brain versus the slower one bits and
slices of this are already becoming a
reality
it's easy to imagine scenarios where
people who care about self-improvement
dear I can say cells improvement look at
their technologies and say I want to be
a better leader I want to be a better
manager I want to be a more persuasive
or influential designer I want to see
what my most compassionate self looks
like I can use textual analysis
sentiment an animal analysis to become
more influential in my emails in my
chats in my presentation
but does my becoming more influential
mean that I'm also becoming more
manipulative I don't want to be
manipulative these are the kinds of
challenges that augmented introspection
create who do we want to be who do we
want to be what kind of people do we
want to be the reason why I focus so
much on employees in the workplace is
that we live in a time where we're not
just concerned about losing our jobs to
smarter machines we're worried about how
do we create value how do we become more
productive
how does 10 years of experience not be
one year of experience 10 times we've
already seen a complete revolution of
digital tools we're already seeing the
first and second generation of BOTS and
agents coming into the workplace
completely understandable not enough not
enough self-improvement is going to come
from selves improvement
[Music]